here now with reaction law professor fox
news contributor uh jonathan turley is
with us uh
i i want to make sure from the legal
perspective that the analysis that we're
giving
is is accurate now there is an
enumerated right to keep and bear arms
that would justify yesterday's decision
on the second amendment
there is no enumerated right when it
comes to the constitution but our
framers and their wisdom anticipated
such conflicts or moments and hence we
have the tenth amendment to a certain
extent i would argue the ninth amendment
uh that sends issues like this back to
the state which seems appropriate in
this case which is why i've always felt
that roe is bad law your thoughts
well you know this is part of what the
court was grappling with you know people
talk about roe v wade as if it's an
inviolate uh decision in fact roe v wade
itself was gutted that privacy-based
analysis that came out of
the 1973 opinion was later removed in
casey and there was a substitute which
gave us the undue burden standard but
rohib was criticized by many liberal
academics i mean people like lawrence
tribe called it a smoke screen
as you saw ginsburg herself said it went
too far
so this wasn't an inviolate decision it
wasn't a decision that was widely
accepted in terms of its analysis
now there are arguments
that can be made under the constitution
for this privacy or equal protection or
due process right but the court clearly
didn't see that and their argument was
not that abortion should be unlawful
they're not saying anything about what
should happen to abortion they're saying
more who should make that decision and
they said in in the opinion that in 1973
they essentially stopped a political
debate
that was going on in the country and
what they said today was
have at it have that debate have 33
330 000 million americans make the
decision rather than nine justices
and you're going to see a variation
among the states
most are likely to protect
the right to abortion i'll remind you by
the way sean that in 1973 30 states when
roe was handed down prohibited abortion
and all by the most limited exceptions
so the country has moved on the issue
but this issue is now going to move back
to the country and people will make this
decision state by state is it a fair
statement to say that the odds are zero
that abortion is going to be illegal in
the united states knowing the current
makeup of new york and new jersey and
illinois and california
and even knowing for example mississippi
which which brought this before the
supreme court
they just had a regulation state
regulation of 15 weeks
is that a fair statement
yes in fact the majority of people in
this country are virtually guaranteed to
live in a state where abortion is not
going to be unlawful you're going to
have states like california new york
illinois that are obviously going to
remain robustly protective states and
then even states with with republican
governors like
like virginia today senator uh yunkin
said look i'd like to pursue a
mississippi-like rule and he says but
i'm also willing to compromise let's
talk let's see what a a reasonable
compromise is that was part of the
vision that framers had for the
federalism model is that with 50 states
today working on problems there's a
chance you can come up with creative
compromises that out of all of that
experimentation can become can come a
resolution and so
i think that what you're going to see is
you're going to have a number of states
in the short term they're going to move
on these trigger laws that are going to
ban abortion except in very limited
circumstances but in the majority for
the majority of people in this country
the post row world will not be
dramatically different from the row
world in the sense that they're living
in states where that right will be
protected let me let me play for you
chuck schumer on the steps of the
supreme court and i want to get your
thoughts on this
i want to tell you gorsuch i want to
tell you kavanaugh you have released the
whirlwind and you will pay the price
you won't know what hit you if you go
forward with these awful decisions
you've released the whirlwind you will
pay the price you won't know what hit
you jonathan turley you're a great
lawyer if that was me on the steps of
the supreme court um why do i think
there'd be consequences that i'd have to
face as a result of saying something
like that
and i don't think you can get me out
that was one
that was on the lowest points that i
have witnessed in my lifetime
in terms of the supreme court and how it
is being treated to have the now
senate majority leader making threats
calling out two justices by name
really shocked all of us
and this is at an age of rage you know
that people are addicted to rage and
certainly senator schumer knows that i
don't think he was calling for violence
but what he was doing was reckless that
there are people that hear those types
of words and they take a much different
meaning a very violent meaning we saw
that in front of justice kavanaugh's
house and today we're seeing the same
failure of leadership as these
politicians go out and say things that
are not true you know the vice president
harris and speaker pelosi talking about
how this opinion endangers things like
uh um
multiracial or interracial marriages and
and contraceptive protections
the court went to an extraordinary
degree to swat down those arguments i i
don't think i've ever seen an opinion
where the court repeatedly returns to
this issue and says this is not going to
endanger those rights it keeps on coming
back and saying
that saying that we are going to extend
this opinion to things like marriage or
contraception is simply untrue there was
only one justice who said that there
might be grounds to re-examine these
cases one the five other justices in the
majority expressly said that is not
going to be the case
and yet that's being ignored i had one
law professor respond to me today and
said well we just don't believe anything
they say anyway well then what's the
point of legal analysis if you're just
going to say that everything's a lie
that certainly makes our task rather
easy
but it's not a lie these justices made
drew a very clear line abortion in their
view is unique and this does not extend
to those rights
jonathan turley great analysis thank you
as always appreciate you being with us
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else